[Music]
flanked by two powerful European nations
the English Channel has long been one of
the world's most important maritime
passages yet for most of its history the
channels rocky shores and stormy weather
made crossing a dangerous prospect
engineers of the early 1800s proposed
numerous plans for spanning the 33
kilometre
their designs included artificial
islands linked by bridges submerged
tubes suspended from floating platforms
and an underwater passage more than
twice the length of any existing tunnel
by the end of the century this last
proposal had captured European
imagination the invention of the tunnel
boring machine and the discovery of a
stable layer of chalk moral below the
seabed made this fantastic tunnel more
feasible but the project's most urgent
obstacles were ones no engineer could
solve at the time Britons viewed their
geographic isolation as a strategic
advantage and fears about French
invasion shut down plans for the tunnel
the rise of aerial warfare rendered
these worries obsolete but new economic
concerns arose to replace them finally
100 years after the initial excavation
the two countries reached an agreement
the tunnel would proceed with private
funding in 1985 a group of French and
British companies invested the modern
equivalent of 14 billion pounds making
the tunnel the most expensive
infrastructure project to date the
design called for three separate tunnels
one for trains to France one for trains
to England and one service tunnel
between them alongside crossover
chambers emergency passages and air
ducts this amounted to over 200
kilometers of tunnels in 1988 workers
began excavating from both sides
planning to meet in the middle
early surveys of the French coast
revealed the site was full of fault
lines these small cracks let water seep
into
so engineers had to develop waterproof
boring machines the British anticipated
drier conditions and forged ahead with
regular borers but only months into the
work water flooded in through undetected
fissures to drill in this wet chalk the
British had to use grout to seal the
cracks created in the borers wake and
even work ahead of the main borer to
reinforce the chalk about to be drilled
with these obstacles behind them both
teams began drilling at full speed
boring machines weighing up to 1,300
tons drilled at nearly 3.5 meters per
hour as they dug they installed lining
rings to stabilize the tunnel behind
them making way for support wagons
following each machine even at top speed
work had to proceed carefully the chalk
layer followed a winding path between
unstable rock and clay punctured by over
100 boring holes made by previous
surveyors furthermore both teams had to
constantly check their coordinates to
ensure they were on track to meet within
two centimetres of each other to
maintain this delicate trajectory the
borers employed satellite positioning
systems as well as paleontologists who
used excavated fossils to confirm they
were at the right depth during
construction the project employed over
13,000 people and cost the lives of ten
workers but after two and a half years
of tunnelling the two sides finally made
contact
British worker Graham [ __ ] emerged on the
French side becoming the first human to
cross the channel by land since the Ice
Age there was still work to be done from
installing crossover chambers and
pumping stations to laying over a
hundred miles of tracks cables and
sensors but on May 6th 1994 an opening
ceremony marked the tunnels completion
full public service began 16 months
later with trains for passengers and ray
shuttles for cars and trucks today the
Channel Tunnel services over 20 million
passengers a year transporting riders
across the channel in just 35 minutes
unfortunately not everyone has the
privilege of making this trip legally
thousands of refugees have tried to
enter Britain through the tunnel in
sometimes fatal attempts these tragedies
have transformed the tunnels southern
entrance into an ongoing site of
conflict
hopefully the structures history can
serve as a reminder that Humanity is at
their best when breaking down barriers
fissures leaks and cracks were a major
obstacle in the construction of the
English Channel Tunnel but what if there
was a type of concrete that could heal
itself it's not science fiction it's a
mind boggling material that could change
the future of engineering learn more
with this video or stay on track and
explore the London Underground
[Music]